hier soir la planète entière a retenu
son souffle lorsqu'une bombe russe est
tombée dans le périmètre de la grande
centrale nucléaire ukrainienne de
zaporizhya et a provoqué un incendie
puis la pression est retombée terros nos
villes is of radiation hentati
integrity of de
compromis cette centrale la plus
importante en europe comprend six
réacteurs nucléaires construits par les
russes eux-mêmes entre 1985 et 1995 et
elle fournit près du quart de
l'électricité du pays concrètement la
frapna d'eau magique un bâtiment
administratif mais vu les dimensions de
la centrale on a envisagé le pire des
scénarios c'est vraiment pire mobile
multiplié par cinq ou six au cas où on
aurait une attaque ciblée sur donc ce
sept centrales nucléaires mais là je
pense que l'on est dans la
science-fiction fort heureusement où le
scénario de catastrophe et je pense que
ceci a été évité et sera évitée dans les
faits ce scénario catastrophe est assez
improbable disent les experts parce que
ce type de centrale construit un peu
partout dans le monde est un modèle en
matière de sécurité par exemple le coeur
du réacteur 1 véritables tombeaux d'aci
pu supporter d'immenses pressions y la
centrale elle même recouverte de
boucliers humains pourraient résister à
l'impact causé par la chute d'un avion
de ligne en plus de ces réacteurs n'ont
été remis à jour pour augmenter leur
sécurité après les événements fukushima
donc c'est
à peu près ce que de mieux dans le monde
même la comparaison avec l'accident de
tchernobyl en 1986 dont le réacteur a
surchauffé en raison du manque de
liquide de refroidissement est difficile
à faire
le fait qu' il ya des systèmes trois
systèmes de refroidissement c'est
beaucoup plus
important que celle de tchernobyl
mais bien sûr il ya toujours le facteur
humain qui peut changer la donne dans
ses
annales mais veulent
l' agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a invité la russie et l'ukraine
à une négociation en vue de garantir la
sécurité des sites nucléaires mises en
danger par la guerre
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal
[Musique]